sudan
najin
fatu
these are the last three northern white
rhinos left in the world
they're here at old pejita conservancy
in kenya
efforts by the staff and veterinarians
are the last chance to keep these rhinos
from going extinct completely
my name is dr stephen gullu
i work at alpergeta conservancy as the
wildlife veterinarian
poachers have been the main cause of the
loss of this subspecies there's huge
demand for rhino horn and rhino products
if there wasn't demand for rhino horn
there wouldn't be poaching it's like the
war against terrorism it's a very
dangerous kind of situation
the northern white rhinos were brought
to the conservancy in 2009 from a zoo in
the czech republic
even though they live on the conservancy
they're still at risk from poachers to
keep the rhinos safe they're watched
around the clock
my name is zachary mutai i work for
unprecedented conservancy as northern
white trainer aid keeper
i do love ultra wild animals but my
favorite one is our rhino
it's my passion
i know when they're happy when they're
nervous and everything
sudan is the last male of the northern
white right now here is my favorite
friend
it's the most gentle
the keepers are keenly aware that the
rhinos have been brought here to live
out their last days
so far breeding efforts have been
unsuccessful
and though the chances are slim around
30 percent the last hope they have is to
try in vitro fertilization
if ivf succeed then they will not get
extinct
we might be lucky we might be
unsuccessful
but we are trying all means to see if we
can save them
you